[Musik]
hey leute heute gibt es ein
salatdressing rezept und zwar zeige ich
euch jetzt mal folgendes ihr werdet
jetzt alle erkennen was das für ein
salat ist nämlich ein gemischter salat
eller vom piano sozusagen und wir kaufen
uns also haben sie nicht von uns immer
ein salat dazu wenn wir uns nur dann
holt immer und da ist unser lieblings
dressing das cola senf dressing und ich
habe mir ein bisschen was vorbereitet um
euch zu zeigen wie ihr das zu hause
nachmachen können wir benötigen frischen
rucola den habe ich schon gewaschen und
trocken gemacht außerdem fettarmer
joghurt wer mag etwas tabasco pfeffer
und neutrales öl ich hab sonnenblumenöl
helles balsamico-essig hier habe ich
noch salz senf und honig und ich fange
direkt an das soll ein sehr stilles
rezept sein was die jeder von euch
machen kann
ihr nehmt euch euren rucola und er muss
jetzt so fein wie möglich gehackt werden
das klappt am allerbesten mit einem
wiegemesser und ich habe jetzt einfach
an und macht das jetzt so eine minute
lang und dann zeigen sie das endergebnis
und so sieht's jetzt aus also richtig
schön fein und gegeben jetzt das zum
joghurt genauso wie alle anderen zutaten
vermengen das und dann ist uns adressen
auch schon fertig
[Musik]
am ende könnte jetzt nur mit salz und
pfeffer abschmecken jeder gaumen ist ja
anders aber ich schreibe euch meine ganz
genauen mengenangaben wirklich half
allen genau unten in die info box macht
unbedingt nach wenn euch dieses video
gefallen hat unbedingten daumen hoch
lassen und das abo nicht vergessen leute
es ist komplett gratis
und dann verpasst ihr auch kein video
mehr von uns und wir machen jetzt noch
vapiano de in welches sind seht ihr dann
immer im nächsten video oder vielleicht
kommt auch davor aus auf jeden fall
fleißig kommentieren was als nächstes in
meiner vapiano reihe online kommen soll
und dann freuen wir uns wenn wir beim
nächsten mal auch wieder dabei sein
[Musik]
auch noch gebraucht